Bill Gates once bought a single book for
30 million dollars back in 1994 Gates
bought the Codex Lester it's the science
Diary of Leonardo da Vinci from the year
1510. so why would Bill Gates pay the
equivalent of 50 million dollars in
today's terms for a book The Diary
contains drawings theories and
observations on things like the movement
of water the Luminosity of the Moon and
why fossils of sea creatures can be
found on mountains once he secured Da
Vinci's book Bill Gates had every single
page digitally scanned and then in a
surprise move he released them as
screensavers and wallpapers in Windows
98 now that's pretty damn cool